right as though nobody's watching
because nobody's watching
suspense is all about making promises to
your reader
you're telling your reader i know
something you don't know but i promise
i'll tell you if you keep going
writing a novel is about a process it is
not all about inspiration and craft
this class provides practical tools a
roadmap to turn your idea
into a story take the pressure
off yourself every single idea has been
done over and over
you don't need a big idea you need big
house
how do you create tension how do you
build character what's the moral gray
array that we're going to be writing in
there are
elements that must be in a good story
the contract
the clock and the crucible
[Music]
if you're not sure what to write write
the wrong thing a few times
and let that be the process by which you
find the right thing
put a secret in a character's backstory
write your villain
first because your villain is the one
who's going to define your hero
there were some dark times when i wasn't
actually sure i could accomplish this
there will be days you just don't know
if you can do it
and on those days what is going to save
you is your process
you do not need to have total mastery of
your subject matter to start a novel
only to finish it write until you're
ready to show the world what you've done
i'm dan brown and this is my master
[Music]
class
you